der polnische kollege der stand auf der
rechten spur kein licht anging waren
blinker an so und ich habe keine chance
gehabt auszuweichen wie gesagt also wie
gesagt ja es hat nicht gereicht also
aber ich gehen dann halt mal getroffen
weil ein scheibenwischer nicht
funktioniert kommt es zu einem unfall
auf der autobahn ausgelöst durch eine
folgenschwere kettenreaktion
sonntagabend auf dem berliner ring
zwischen mühlenbeck und birkenwerder im
norden der hauptstadt drei männer halt
mit ihrem auto auf dem rechten
fahrstreifen an und reparieren ihren
scheibenwischer eine fatale idee denn
hier im baustellenbereich ist die a 10
auf zwei fahrspuren verengt eine stand
spur gibt es nicht etwa 200 meter sind
es noch bis zur nächsten parkbucht doch
so lange wollen die männer offenbar
nicht warten auch verzichten sie darauf
warnblinker einzuschalten oder das auto
anderweitig abzusichern und dann kommt
es wie es kommen muss plötzlich kracht
ein audi ungebremst in das heck des
parkenden wagens durch die wucht des
aufpralls wird das parken der auto nach
vorne geschoben einer der männer die am
scheibenwischer hantieren wird erst in
die windschutzscheibe des autos und dann
einen zehn meter hohen abhang hinunter
geschleudert er wird lebensgefährlich
verletzt weil der unfall in der
baustelle passiert kann keine
rettungsgasse gebildet werden die retter
müssen 700 meter laufen erreichen den
verletzten nur schwer ein dramatischer
unfall mit schlimmen folgen ausgelöst
durch einen defekten scheibenwischer